many Democrats who were running for
office right now are going oh man the
ship is sinking the guy's head ain't
right and we got to distance ourselves
from them uh here is black lesbian press
secretary Corrine Jean-Pierre and she's
having trouble running cover for him
when asked uh who's gonna you know
invite Biden to come campaign with him
in the last month giving a speech
tomorrow in D.C he's given fundraisers
in New Jersey New York he campaigned
with Democratic governor candidates in
Massachusetts in Maryland and he was in
California Oregon and Colorado next week
yes he has plans to be in Pennsylvania
and Florida but behind closed doors with
two of the democratic candidates there's
a White House Office of political
affairs have they been getting phone
calls from candidates in some of those
other states Arizona Nevada Georgia
Wisconsin Michigan to say we'd love to
have the president come look I don't
have any calls to read out we don't have
any calls or personal conversations to
read out how the hell would she have
call records what is she the press
secretary or something she doesn't know
who's calling the president and asking
them to campaign for him of course
that's complete nonsense if they wanted
Biden there she would be telling people
buy it in schedule by the way Biden's
going to Arizona tomorrow to campaign
with Katie Hobbs by the way Biden's
going over to Ohio to campaign with Tim
Ryan Biden's going to swing by Georgia
and campaign with uh with Stacey Abrams
by the way I thought my George accent
was pretty good I really thought it was
we're in Georgia now
I'm basically doing some version of big
daddy blanche's father and The Golden
Girls
um
but yes they don't want Biden because
they know what's about to happen
although as I always say give the devil
is due like anything can happen over
these next two weeks nuclear war coveted
six you never know
um but it's not looking good and people
don't want to be attached to Biden how
how much do people not want to be
attached to Biden well here is a video
from Fox Business on how bad it actually
is getting for the elderly man
pretending to be president more bad news
for President Biden this morning a new
Fox News poll shows that if the election
were to happen today only 33 percent of
Voters would vote for President Biden
while a 54 percent say that they would
vote for someone else okay so I always
tell you guys I I try not to get too
caught up in polls because it depends on
the sample size you know it depends
who's picking up the phone generally the
people that are being pulled they skew a
little bit older in age that being said
older people tend to vote it's a little
screwy but if if they're roughly right
on that that 33 percent of people who
voted provided would vote for him again
I mean we're told the guy got 81 million
votes I can do some basic math in my
head where I think we're at about 27
million people would vote for him this
time that is not good if you're a
Democrat like that ain't good at all